If you can dodge a wrench, you can dodge a
ball.
DodgeBall came out in theaters in 2004 and
we've been quoting it since.
While it's hard to believe that DodgeBall
came out nearly 15 years ago, let's take a
second to see where the movie's main players
find themselves nowadays.
Vince Vaughn was already well-known for Swingers
and Old School when he starred in DodgeBall,
but the film marked the beginning of a new
phase in Vaughn's career: that of big budget,
big screen comedies.
The next year, he appeared in Wedding Crashers,
which solidified his status as a comedy leading
man.
Vaughn's next movies included a number of
films that he also helped to write and produce,
including The Break-Up, Couples Retreat, and
The Internship.
He also reunited with DodgeBall co-star Ben
Stiller in The Watch.
"Tell me about yourself.
I know you got a wife.
Have any kids?
How old?"
"Zero years old.
No kids."
Vaughn later took up more dramatic work, including
a starring role in True Detective Season 2.
He also had a supporting role in Best Picture
nominee Hacksaw Ridge.
His most recent roles veer toward "family"
entertainment, literally.
He nabbed a recurring role as Chet Stevenson
on the Netflix animated comedy F is for Family.
He also had a part in Fighting with My Family,
a movie about the rise of WWE star Paige.
Ben Stiller has had a varied career as an
actor, writer, and director, and 2004 seemed
like a watershed year for him.
While Stiller was already famous for Meet
the Parents and Zoolander, 2004 saw him starring
in hits Meet the Fockers, Starsky & Hutch,
and Along Came Polly.
He has continued to be hugely successful since,
lending his voice to the Madagascar series,
appearing in the Night at the Museum franchise,
and writing, directing, and starring in Tropic
Thunder.
He also appeared in The Meyerowitz Stories
opposite Adam Sandler, which got a standing
ovation at Cannes in 2017.
He's also moved behind the camera and into
more dramatic work recently, producing and
directing the based-on-a-true-story prison
break miniseries Escape at Dannemora, which
earned 12 nominations at the 2019 Emmy Awards.
Stiller hasn't forgotten his DodgeBall days.
He recently organized a charity dodgeball
competition for his Ben Stiller Foundation
focused around the film.
Stiller was able to reunite many of his co-stars
for the promo video, which gave fans the chance
to play dodgeball with him and his famous
friends.
The game was played live on Today with the
anchors, fans, and Justin Long.
Christine Taylor had a solid career on screen
before DodgeBall.
She was best known for playing Marcia Brady
in two Brady Bunch movies.
Other roles include parts in The Wedding Singer,
Zoolander, and The Craft.
Following DodgeBall, she appeared in License
to Wed and more recently Little Boxes.
Taylor has appeared in a number of projects
with Stiller over the years, including Zoolander,
Tropic Thunder, and Arrested Development,
and with good reason.
The two were married in 2000 after meeting
on the unaired pilot Heat Vision and Jack.
The pair announced their separation in May
2017.
Luckily, their split was amicable, so we can't
rule out them working together again someday.
Justin Long earned himself a concussion from
his character's inability to dodge a ball,
but he also earned himself pretty lofty status
in Hollywood.
DodgeBall marked one of his earliest roles
following small parts in Galaxy Quest and
Crossroads, but it was just the start for
the young star.
He starred opposite Lindsay Lohan in Herbie:
Fully Loaded the following year.
From there, he starred in a number of comedies
including The Break-Up and Accepted.
He moved into action territory with Live Free
or Die Hard and went back to horror with Drag
Me to Hell.
He also lent his voice to the Alvin and the
Chipmunks film trilogy series as the titular
troublemaking rodent.
The role he's best known for, though?
Playing Mac in Apple's "Get a Mac" ad campaign,
which ran from 2006 to 2009.
Stephen Root unleashed his inner Hulk as Gordon
in DodgeBall.
Best known for his playing Milton in Office
Space, the veteran character actor has kept
busy since DodgeBall.
Shortly after the film was released, Root
appeared in the romantic comedy Just Friends.
Root has found himself in small parts in many
high profile films.
The actor has appeared in No Country For Old
Men, Selma, The Ballad Of Buster Scruggs and
more.
He also had a part in the hit horror film
Get Out, playing gallery owner Jim Hudson.
Root has also had an extensive career in television,
appearing on True Blood, 24, and Boardwalk
Empire.
In the 90s he also gave life to two iconic
TV roles: angry boss Jimmy James on NewsRadio
and sad sack Bill on King of the Hill.
In 2018, he landed the role of Monroe Fuches,
handler and mentor of the titular character
on Bill Hader's pitch-black hitman comedy
Barry.
For his work in the show's second season,
Root received his first-ever Emmy nomination.
Joel David Moore had an adorable love affair
with the other team in DodgeBall, and has
continued to charm audiences with his sweetness.
DodgeBall was one of Moore's earliest roles,
but he quickly followed it up with slasher
Hatchet and the much-maligned The Hottie and
the Nottie.
Moore has also been a consistent television
guest star, appearing on multiple episodes
of Bones, Medium, and in a supporting role
on the short-lived ABC drama series Forever.
"Pure gold, 24 karat, unalloyed."
"Lucas, please."
"Sorry.
Sorry."
You may also recognize him from his music
video appearances, with the actor starring
in videos from Fall Out Boy and Katy Perry.
Moore's most notable role to date was as Norm
Spellman in James Cameron's Avatar.
He'll be kept busy for the next few years
with the role, with Moore set to play Spellman
in all four of the planned Avatar sequels.
Chris Williams was already an established
actor when he played Dwight in DodgeBall,
and he continues to be a popular actor today.
Williams followed up the film with guest appearances
on shows like Reno 911!, Monk, and Weeds.
Williams landed recurring roles on shows like
Californication and Curb Your Enthusiasm.
He recently starred as Eddie on The Great
Indoors, which was cancelled after just one
season.
He also appears on Silicon Valley as Hoover,
the loyal assistant to evil tech boss Gavin
Belson.
You'll recognize Steve the Pirate if you're
a fan of sci-fi, as actor Alan Tudyk was already
well-established as Wash in cult hit Firefly.
Not long after DodgeBall, he played Wash again
in Firefly sequel film Serenity.
Tudyk has had many high profile roles, with
appearances in 3:10 to Yuma, and Transformers:
Dark of the Moon.
And in the final season of the Netflix zombie
comedy Santa Clarita Diet, Tudyk replaced
Firefly costar Nathan Fillion in the role
of Gary, a decomposing, disembodied head.
You also heard Tudyk as the droid K-2SO in
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story.
The actor has some prolific pipes, lending
his voice to huge films like Frozen, Zootopia,
and Moana.
Gary Cole played the straight man of the DodgeBall
commentating duo as Cotton McKnight.
While you've likely seen Cole elsewhere on
the big screen, most famously as Bill Lumbergh
in Office Space, you're more likely to have
seen him on the small screen.
He's had a prolific career as a guest star
on TV shows like Supernatural and 30 Rock.
He's also had recurring roles on Entourage,
Suits, and Veep, the last of which got him
an Emmy nomination.
Cole is also a well-known voice actor, who
has had prominent roles in properties like
Harvey Birdman: Attorney at Law, Kim Possible,
and Bob's Burgers.
Jason Bateman delivered some of DodgeBall's
most memorable lines in his role as commentator
Pepper.
"It's a bold strategy, Cotton, let's see if
it pays off for 'em."
The outlandish part was a huge departure from
his most notable role as straight man Michael
Bluth on Arrested Development.
Few actors have racked up as lengthy a TV
resume as Bateman, who landed his first small
screen role in 1981, as James Cooper Ingalls
on Little House on the Prairie.
He earned two Emmy nominations and won a Golden
Globe for Arrested Development, but he won
an Emmy in 2019 for directing an episode of
the stark crime drama Ozark.
He also stars in the show as money launderer
Marty Byrde.
Bateman also has many major movies parts,
including starring roles in the Horrible Bosses
series, and Game Night.
The late Rip Torn portrayed mildly mad dodgeball
coach Patches O'Houlihan in DodgeBall, but
Hank Azaria played the character as a younger
man in a training video.
Azaria has been a major part of some of the
biggest and funniest shows and movies of the
past three decades.
He's been a utility voice actor on The Simpsons
since its inception, portraying, among others,
Chief Wiggum, Moe, Carl, Superintendent Chalmers,
Comic Book Guy, and Kwik-E-Mart proprietor
Apu.
In 2017, he turned Jim Brockmire, a baseball
announcer he played in a Funny or Die sketch,
into a full-length sitcom from IFC called
Brockmire.
"We have run out of cheeks to turn, people!
We're fresh out of 'em!"
Azaria also portrayed Gargamel in two big-screen
Smurfs movies, while enjoying a recurring
role on Showtime's Ray Donovan.
While dodgeball isn't a real professional
sport, filmmakers managed to keep the playing
sequences as realistic and above board as
possible.
Portraying the tournament referee in the film's
climactic showdown, we've got Al Kaplon, an
actor and real-life minor league baseball
umpire.
Kaplon called balls and strikes for a decade
as an official before turning to acting.
He first played, what else, an umpire in the
baseball movie Talent for the Game.
He followed that up with small parts on episodes
of The X-Files and the sports-themed sitcom
Inside Schwartz.
He also did commercials for Toyota and Nike.
He played the Memorial Field umpire in 61*,
an HBO movie about Roger Marist's home run
chase.
At least he got to call something other than
baseball in DodgeBall.
Following that high-profile gig, he was named
the head referee on NBC's short-lived revival
of American Gladiators.
Following small roles in S.W.A.T. and The
Rundown, DodgeBall was Jamal Duff's third
movie, and the actor portrayed Me'Shell Jones,
dodgeball monster and loyal second-in-command
to White Goodman.
Duff strikes an imposing figure in real life,
too.
The 6'7" actor played as a defensive end and
defensive tackle in the NFL in the 1990s.
He also played for the Los Angeles Xtreme,
league champions in the old XFL's one-and-only
season.
And in the 2000s, he decided to give acting
a shot.
After DodgeBall, Duff booked dozens of roles
in movies and TV shows, often playing bouncers,
guards, or just general tough guys.
This includes a security guard on Future Man
and "Tough Guy #1" on an episode of Fresh
Off the Boat.
His most high-profile work to date is a recurring
role as Zeke on Brooklyn Nine-Nine, the brother-in-law
of Terry Jeffords.
Like her on-screen DodgeBall love interest
Justin Long, Julie Gonzalo was well into her
20s when she portrayed a teenager, specifically
cheerleader Amber.
Around the time of DodgeBall's release in
2004, Gonzalo played a lot of teens, such
as in Freaky Friday and A Cinderella Story.
In 2006, Gonzalo scored her biggest early
career role, as Hearst College student Parker
Lee on the third season of cult classic Veronica
Mars.
Gonzalo is also well-known for her role as
Pamela Rebecca Barnes on TNT's Dallas sequel
series.
Along with guest star gigs on series ranging
from Castle to CSI: Miami to Grey's Anatomy,
Gonzalo landed one other major role on a short-lived
show, playing attorney Maggie Dekker in legal
dramedy Eli Stone.
Even if you've seen DodgeBall hundreds of
times, you probably wouldn't be able to pick
Missi Pyle out of a line-up.
The gorgeous actress made a huge transformation
for the part of Globo Gym player Fran, going
from blonde to dark brunette and adding in
a unibrow for good measure.
Since DodgeBall, Pyle has gone back to her
normal self, but she's had good luck as a
character actress throughout her career.
Shortly after DodgeBall, Pyle played Violet's
overbearing mother in Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory.
She later appeared in Gone Girl and Jumanji:
Welcome to the Jungle.
Pyle has popped up all over the small screen,
including appearances on sketch comedy show
Inside Amy Schumer, Netflix original Lady
Dynamite, and CBS primetime anchor Two and
a Half Men.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.